I actually think that winters in LA are
really bad because the houses aren't
insulated so at night I have to wear
sweat pants to bed the harshest winter
I've ever experienced is sweat shirt
maybe a jacket
it's hailed a few times think one time
it rains it's never bad I mean clearly
it's 79 degrees outside right now and
I'm wearing a sweater because I'm kind
of cold the first time I saw snowfall in
person was a few years ago in Iceland of
all places I know people are gonna be
like oh Californians can't can't handle
the cold weather whatever I can't handle
the cold weather hell yeah I know what
this is salt that's all I mean I know
you throw this on icy stuff cuz I've
seen home alone and there's like the
weirds like salt guy just helps you so
you don't slip around break your neck my
hands not going anywhere there should be
some nice traction
it makes the snow melt yeah so it
doesn't stay on the road you shovel the
snow shovel the snow and then you put
this on the ice and then melts it and
usually back the hell off shrinks the
snow up got it your shoes get ruined
that's not okay did you eat it it's your
uses for cooking mmm this goes on the
floor
I have no idea what this could be
this looks like a death trap this for
your sled no change right or it's like a
really cool ladder these are four tires
yeah yeah notice no chains that's an
easy one
I assumed they were chain chains like
chains yeah me too like what rappers
wear contains it's like how this
technology not gotten better where you
don't have to use these I mean I have no
idea to use this this seems like a
prehistoric type of thing like you could
probably tear up the road with these
things that we're not careful like
Middle Ages like for your horses it's
just a hassle that's just what it is be
careful out there cold people
East Coast's blow on your hands you're
gonna put your hands and fancy little
pouches I'm tired
Oh yours is warm cause you didn't expose
it to the air oh okay
professional in California if I had
these on the East Coast I would just be
like heating them up and then like
throwing up in the snow so it melts
you've never felt cold you don't know
hold on so is this a joke cats pee and
poop in this we have kitty litter also
know what kitty litter in sunny
California grab cats why would you also
throw cat litter on the stone odor
control maybe you got some smelly snow
maybe your cat wants to take a dump in
the wilderness that's kitty litter all
right oh it's strong throwing maybe when
you don't have enough money for that
fancy salt you were throwing around
earlier you got it get this kitty litter
going well see how traction e it is this
is not a good choice I don't think you
guys are I don't I think you should be
evaluated people actually like have this
in their trunk no they don't no they
don't I don't believe I feel like your
thing with us oh it's a thing okay okay
you guys must all have a lot of cats as
well no oh my god below zero no no I
can't even handle a lukewarm weather
probably like 15 minutes I could never
survive if my car was stuck I would call
triple-a triple-a can't get I mean I
would like to think that I would do okay
and like Chicago but I'm pretty sure
people are gonna laugh at me once they
see this video you should come stay with
us in California
sunny California it's really nice look
behind us I'm so sorry